Nguyên Lua, hát hát lên màu mang u thuộc lối lối lối khi lời mù Trung nghiên Lua hát động mạnh nhất thế giới.
Đà bắt đầu đường phung trào thứ 3 mi chiến đúng sịp kỳ nghiệp 1 năm kể tụi ký chủi phung trào hiện nay khởi phát.
Theo cụ quan khảo xác địa chết hoa kỳ USGS, họ đặc lối lối tài diễn vào khoảng 20m, mười phút theo dõi phương,
bởi các cuộc dùng nhằm bắt đầu cao từ 12.000 mệt.
USGS cho biết chỉ trong thời gian sư đỏ, mình rút lửa phía bác của Halim mà u mang u đã tạo ra cuộc dùng nhằm cao tới khoảng 40,000 mệt.
Khi loa ea đã linh tục của các đợt phung trào giám đoạn kể từ ngày 2018, mẹ hai năm hành nhiên không trào mệt tư.
Chui ớ tại Halim mẹ u mang u, mỗi đợt phung trào thứ kéo sạy nhiều tự nông hồ của thế linh tới 1 hài tiến.
Sau đó là tất cả dạy dạy niện tĩnh kéo sạy hồn hai tồn.
Giờ chúng đẹp trên Mỹ đang tích tục thông thỏ chật trẻ dễ biến để đánh giáng huy cơ, đồng thời khẳng lình,
hiện cho có môi đây giói chức tiếp đồ về các khu dân gú lần cắt.